we're gonna go meet at this restaurant
I'm like messaging Chris I'm like What's
the reservation name he replies with the
name Barry chopsticks
so I'm going in there and I'm like yeah
I have a restaurant reservation for
Barry Chopsticks
he looks at me like
[Music]
Chase I am here with the boys and we
have a special guest as you can see are
you a special guest
I'm just here with the boys as usual
about to get affable
I haven't seen you guys in a while I
walk I've this is my fourth fifth time
on the show [ __ ] I can't remember
anymore
I used to walk into the studio to a
Heroes welcome right I kicked down the
door and I'm like Chris welcome let's
gonna have so much today I walked in
like nobody looked up from their face it
was gone like munching on a salad he's
like Joe was like looking into the
distance and everyone was on his phone
it was like oh it's just the way it is
now
Scarface instead of cocaine there was
salads
I think I think you've come to this
studio more than some staff members
yeah yeah it's good to be back though
it's felt like a wild it's been the last
time you're on was um
it was the charity stream yeah we heated
out as we were all dying and you're like
all right guys see I'm gonna go bed and
I remember going to bed that night at
like 1am and I was rolling to bed like
half dead like and I pulled out my phone
and what she all screaming in pain I was
like and then I hit the off button woke
up like eight hours later and he was
still streaming yeah like the like
regenerated corpse of Joey
everyone looks so dead I just felt so
happy that I wasn't part of it yeah I
mean that was the big mistake of that
stream was just drinking because you
know we were in High Spirits
that's a good fun though the laugh you
lose segment that was really good yeah
yeah yeah and raised a lot of money for
charity yeah yeah like you guys just did
as well I mean you guys yeah what an
amazing segment yeah what an amazing
speaking to charity can't speak your
Charities we did so we did the cycle uh
700 and I'm gonna say 750 it was 750
something because if he was going up
every time I said there is 800 now what
happened was that we the way we
calculated the overall distance we just
put Hokkaido oh sorry how could that day
what can I cycle they said this many
kilometers obviously we didn't we didn't
take the perfect route you didn't yeah
you can't yeah because you would want to
stop and stay at myself
it was cool though we we raised three
hundred thousand dollars three hundred
and sixteen thousand dollars yeah the
IDF Israeli defensive
it's so unfortunate whenever you type in
whenever you type in the idea Google
it got really awkward at the entire
stream people like guys I'm all for
charity fundraising why is it the
Israeli Defense Force it's the it's
immune deficiency Foundation it's there
it's there on the stream it says immune
deficiency Foundation we've got very
heated very political I can't believe
they're supporting this yeah
um no it was good what I didn't like was
being referred to as Jeffries Jeffries
the whole time asking for massages
we had our friend American P Premiere
two coming yeah second half which we
needed because we were dead by the
second half and he like pepped it up and
I was like if you want to come on if you
want to come on the cycle Pete you got
to pay the price back rub time and
people like you're just Jeff reps
it was Chris Broadstone
um yeah but you know to be fair you get
you want to come on the trip you've got
to pay the price
those massages got me through the second
half of the [ __ ] cycle all right
had a personal massage that was so I
spoke about it a bit in one of the other
episodes but I only spoke about kind of
like the technical aspect in the Stream
aspect yeah I didn't really tell any of
the stories or any of the there was a
story stories I heard you guys went to a
racist hotel or something like that I'd
let Chris tell that yeah oh there's not
much to it we went in a hotel and they
were just incredibly not overly
welcoming yeah like how so like it was
it like in a it was like an aggressive
manner or it was like a kind of very
cold manner all right and then
aggressive and then aggressive or
because you know like Japan is very good
at being you know doing the passive
aggressive stuff yeah I mean we there
was a hotel in the middle of nowhere on
the second day literally nothing nowhere
to stay yeah we stopped in this town
called
by the Riverside or something yeah right
there's one place that was open for the
50 kilometer radius of that area and we
tried to book it and they're like no
room at the end we're full oh [ __ ] we
also read a book like a month in advance
we did right there's no rooms and then
we we rang them up and uh we were
running up in English first and that
that didn't go down well so he rang that
we got all of our friends to bring up in
like perfect Japanese but one room but
we needed two rooms one for me and
Connor one for our driver and cameraman
pool and Ian yeah and um but there
wasn't so there to drive all the way
back a hundred kilometers to wakanae to
stay there so it's in waikanae again
yeah the four guys
but we sort of went to check in and the
woman was just really like just wouldn't
like look at me in the face all the
stuff just went like completely silent
the air left it was like oh [ __ ] this is
awkward and I was like oh I don't
suppose you've got one more room
available our friends are in the car
park and they were like no I was like
well they've got to drive all back to
work and I oh it's all right for lava
and they're like
it was just like this is so awkward and
like as we got our room keys we'll be
like oh yeah so they sort of like walked
off and looked like they weren't doing
anything so we're like okay let's go to
our room 10 15 seconds of them just like
not saying anything yeah yeah and they
gave us the key so we started walking
off to our room and then the door opened
and the woman came running out she was
like you've got to pay pay for your room
now like what oh my God Jesus it's like
you did you look like he did hold on
shouting it was right really awkward
really you know just because I it was
just a bit awkward uncomfortable we were
just like oh all right fine you could
have just said so yeah yeah and four
years yeah that was the only real bad
bit and then we did try and get into a
restaurant in wakani which you guys yeah
right
destitute remote city was it McDonald's
honestly I remember when we went to
McDonald's that place was banging out of
like yeah it was like kicking off like
half the town was there I swear to God
it's always full I swear there's twice
I've been there now it's been always
full and there's like always people
taking photos of the Ronald McDonald out
the front of the bed yeah it's the most
northern Ronald McDonald in Japan yeah
Donald McDonald yeah yeah he's called
Donald McDonald in Japan because they
realized Ronaldo is too difficult for
tongue twister yeah I love those I'll
just call it Donald McDonald then yeah
it's hard to sell with Hotel staff if or
any staff in Japan it's like are they
are they always this rude to everyone or
is it just because we're here well I
don't think they'd ever seen a foreign
person there before oh it's so remote
because you had to book it in Japanese
for this website but we also went to a
restaurant in wakanda and it was a
Yakitori chicken skewed restaurant I was
like this is gonna be great I'm gonna
eat the whole restaurant dry walked in
and the guy was like no get out and
we're like oh really yeah like don't
[ __ ] come here I didn't even ask him
there was like empty tables and it
looked like it was like is it open yeah
it's open for another
so those first two days it was just like
oh let's enjoy racism
after that it got better Thomas everyone
was so nice that's really weird there
was a lot of everyone was kind after
that it's just that part of Japan and
maybe they're not racist they're just
very shy and uncomfortable well I think
it's also because like if I mean for one
obviously not a lot of foreigners go up
there like this I feel there's like a
hard line in Hokkaido where you go
anywhere north of there and it's just
immediately like foreigners don't come
here yeah yeah
and South everyone was very nice yeah
because they're probably more used to
foreign
yes we cycled off just as this girl
arrived and she had to deal with our
team in the car who were there not
really bad so she was like I just missed
them I can't go to the next stop either
oh oh we ran into a guy I think he's
from the Czech Republic there and he was
walking from wakanae to kagoshima doing
your road trip in reverse and walking it
over a four-month period yeah
we were just cycling the hagodate and I
saw what I thought was our cameraman
pull up ahead yeah he sort of waved me
over and I was like that's not Paul
that's not Paul at all and he's just a
really nice guy and he's like I've got
plums for you yeah
excellent and he just whipped out some
plums yeah ate the plums and but yeah
he's walking for four months Jesus holy
[ __ ] and he just started his journey
yeah he was two weeks in I think yeah
yeah you started in the very very top of
uh what can I I don't know all the way
to kagoshima Jesus Jesus far out yeah
it's like Homer's Odyssey
the guy tweeted at me on Twitter yeah a
few days before saying oh I might bump
into you and how could I say I'm walking
from the top to bottom I'm like this
guy's lying
and no one does that yeah I'm like
that's that's absurd yeah one no one is
doing that's literally like Forrest Gump
yeah that's what Forest loved it I don't
know it just seemed weird I and it
didn't make sense to me so I was like oh
whatever but then yeah it's like and
it's like you're not even doing it for
Content
what's wrong with you you're just doing
it for fun and I saw that a guy had
stopped him like ahead of me yeah I was
like it must be that dude because like
we're in how could that do what he said
yeah it didn't look like any of our
cameraman or staff yeah so I was like
that's weird as slow as it gets closer I
see the giant backpack I'm like oh my
God it's him yeah it's real Jesus Christ
what a legend though it's all those
roads I would not want to walk on yeah
just there's trucks it's just all trucks
I mean another girl called Melissa yeah
I came out of like a bickery donkey
restaurant and everyone was like talking
to her and getting free crisps and stuff
yeah she brought us like a bunch of
drinks pretty cool I felt no it was
really really great really nice
positive people yeah yeah that's good
aside from just the one few people at
the beginning of the journey pretty much
yeah yeah but it was it was it was tough
though and like we I only nearly killed
Conor once yeah we only had one main
Dragon I heard you guys had a domestic
but full-on domestic about when to wake
up right it's a shame the cameras
weren't rolling because that was a great
like coming up section
have to bleep the c word like four times
in our defense like so this was the
middle of the trip in Sapporo like the
just past the halfway point yeah and
we'd done what was optimistically build
as the easy day right but it was like
the most difficult day um it was only
like 60 kilometers to Sapporo it was
like we'll get there before lunchtime
would be brilliant but then we hit 30
kilometer headwinds and Google was like
take a detour with extra 20 kilometers
and we didn't really look while we were
going oh yeah [ __ ] so Madero Google
[ __ ] us up Google [ __ ] us and we got
this apparel and I was just just wrecked
I was like I don't know how I'm gonna be
able to carry on this yeah and it was
like right we've got three more days and
then odd days and I was like [ __ ] sake
100 it was like 100 kilometers 100
kilometers 164 kilometers yeah it was it
was it was a lot and then I think we had
a 90 to wake up and yeah yeah it was it
was yeah it got heated but then we were
like very quickly we were like all right
cool it Conor was like we worked out
that at the current rate we'd have to
wake up like four o'clock in the morning
yeah I wouldn't be up at 4am for my own
funeral for him for anything especially
like four hours sleep then cycling 150
kilometers
some some days we were really slow yeah
and some days we were really fast it
just depended on the wind the mood the
wind and the how much good road we're on
yeah the road made so like even if it
just had like was a little bump it would
just slow you down so much when you had
like a good paved Road you could just
get that's so much more distance done so
fast yeah I don't know it's weird but I
noticed that I I started off really
strong started getting worse and worse
and Chris definitely got better I think
it turned out my receipt it was too late
the first four days I could barely stand
up I was like the [ __ ] Hobbit that
the first you know hobbling along like
I'm never walking again but then after I
raised my seat I was like oh right she's
really oh this is this is normally yeah
normally when you pedal right your feet
go like this yeah just but Chris's we're
going like like this
everyone in my chat or something what
the [ __ ] and I was running like what are
you doing so yeah my legs are fine on
the second half but I got really bad
back pain from like leaning down leaning
forward yeah yeah that got really bad I
had to take some painkillers to get
through but yeah the sad thing is there
not even the massage could cover for you
well even the Jeffrey Broad Street
massages
[Music]
but uh here's an interesting thing I I
thought you know I'm I'm on this journey
to get the most fittest I've ever been
by the end of the year right this is
Phase One basically of the Marvel weight
loss the abroad in Japan Cinematic
Universe and um
[Laughter]
I started the cycle 84.5 kilograms right
what do you think I was after eight days
750 kilometers 46 000 calories burnt
unless you already know the answer but
what do you think I would see because
Connor told us that weirdly enough he
didn't actually lose as much weight yeah
it depend depends on how much beer you
write because
[ __ ] Dyson one has a beer in front of
him
so that new new thing out really tough
so no I'm not like I'm not that bad
every day
with your water
I want to say you got to like maybe like
close to 80 maybe a little bit under
84.5 to 80. yeah yeah seven days I'd say
around 80. I'd say that's uh let's see
86.5
[ __ ] two kilograms on
I don't know
I got on the scale so I go about to send
those can we [ __ ] go I got the camera
ready stood all right this girl's like
oh
at first I thought it's because I was
eating a lot everything
yeah and I mean a lot because you have
to you have to stay ahead of the sort of
calorie deficit and recycling because
even [ __ ] stomach's like a furnace
when you're cycling fan yeah you put
food in you're like hungry minutes later
yeah and so I was eating so much as like
a preemptive strike on Hunger [ __ ]
take you on hunger and you have to do
this thing called carblading the night
before where you eat like a mountain of
cars yeah two days ago right yeah well
we did it every day
you know you have to eat a lot so I
thought maybe that's why yeah I'm two
kilograms heavier eight days what it
turns out was uh your my muscles were
destroyed after this cycle even now you
know yeah I've got a bit of a hobble
when I walk like someone's taking a
hammer to my kneecap or something and
I'm in a lot of pain even now and uh
basically like because I've destroyed my
muscles they get swollen yeah yeah right
I get you get actual swole yeah swollen
Japan right so my muscles are like
really big and ridiculous and filled
with water and I think that is why I so
it's waterways
I think all their muscles are really
stiff so I think it's that and I'm going
to weigh myself again three days and
pray to God I've lost some weight I'm
gonna be really [ __ ] depressed I
think I got I look a bit thinner I don't
know though maybe it's my oh my head you
you def you definitely look better yeah
yeah that's for sure because you walked
in today and the first thing I noticed
like damn Chris you are you looking good
man looking thinner yeah looking for
looking like 10 more affable man yeah
people made fun of my like big like
Calves they call me mutable yeah pretty
[ __ ] masks they do look like tumorous
they do they do some call it muscle
I've never seen cars that look like that
it looks like someone's got baseball
back to the back
I feel fit I do feel fit that's good
that's good that's what's important
what's the next what's up what's phase
two what's phase two phase two yeah it's
uh it's called a Spartan Race and I've
got to run five kilometers up a mountain
in Niger and then do 20 obstacles like
monkey bars and under the barbed wire
and all this [ __ ] oh God you know and
I'm I think that'll be harder than the
cycle obviously it's it's not a long
endurance thing like the cycle yeah it's
really really intense yeah it's some
pretty sounds like a Navy SEAL training
regimen yeah it kind of is yeah the sort
of guys that I've seen training for it
like yeah they're like Next Level
Fitness I also feel like that's gonna be
harder than the cycle because like the
cycle you're predominantly only using
you know yeah but with that one it's
like your whole body
10 days I'd rather do that yeah
I have been running and doing various
other things I better start loading on
those carbs
like how do you eat like 8 000 calories
a day you just cut like a reasonable
like person just can't eat that many
calories a day yeah like because some
days we were burning like that much I
can do it yeah
I'm convinced there's energy realities
are just garbage
why are they garbage you just hate jelly
I just think they're just it's just like
oh as the representative character
I I just think they just [ __ ] jelly
like I just pour like a mountain of
sugar in it and call it a day I mean it
gives you like the energy
[Music]
yeah so you can just squeeze it it's
just much easier to into because when
I'm on like a shoot for example and I
just need like a quick intake because I
missed lunch or something Jelly's
perfect that's that's the main thing
they Market it as energy jelly but it's
mostly just like a get a meal in you
quick yeah yeah you're bought out by big
jelly company
this this message is not spawning you
just you just hate jelly in general you
know jelly jelly beautiful
yeah it's just the worst way for Conor
to intake anything it's just like you
bring him jellies like no no get that
away from me I mean what's this nonsense
about you not liking oranges you see
oranges of [ __ ]
you you're not the same are you of
course not no no don't try to listen to
a ganging up thing on me they are just
why not it's so easy what's what's your
least favorite fruit Chris since we all
I think I like all fruits equal you're
like awful what's your favorite fruit
bananas oh okay okay good stuff good
they are they're the best they're the
best they're the best portion sized
fruits but what have you got against
oranges I'm convinced you just go
through addiction every morning like we
actually have a thyroid about today
Aardvark yes
what's the one for one line that you
said in the cycling version and it was
Aardvark as well which we use as the
example it's the first word
um uh yeah no I just uh I don't think
they taste very good and their texture
is not very good uh but he likes
chocolate oranges yeah we'll talk about
orange is good though
the combination of the flavors bounces
only Terry's chocolate orange yeah
they're very good I gotta say I I I
can't remember what I named as my least
favorite fruit in the [ __ ] fruit
argument that we had but I want to take
it back I think
um I was thinking about it and I'm like
pears does is does anyone actually stand
by pets really yeah they're good they're
not they're nobody's favorite but yeah
but if I'm giving a pair I'll be like
yeah [ __ ] yeah Pearson dishes are great
too oh yeah that's a pair that's good
I mean because Japanese pears and like
the the could be worse though those
pairs are like different in my opinion
like the the yolnashi and the and the
actual like Japanese like round pairs I
feel they're different
what you just said things
the Japanese pair yeah like Nashi yeah
Nashi like noshi pears and like standard
Western pairs I feel different
almost
oh these ones yeah yeah the the round
ones the rounder ones those ones I
prefer it looks like an apple but tastes
like a pear Asian pear yeah I prefer
those over the pear-shaped pears fruit
cakes I don't know what they're called
turn into like a fruit ranking episode
isn't it yeah
Jesus oh my God someone trash days Chris
but uh it's cool when you just think
that when you come out from the tour
you'll be like where's Chris gone he's
just say where's me guys enhancement fit
now because after the spotlight and all
the other things like you wanted to bet
me some money so so Chris said that by
the time I'm back from America he'll
have a six-pack and I was like let's put
some money yeah yeah yeah yeah a
thousand dollars let's do it let's bet
and he was like well you know
[Music]
November
second
November 28th or something then I'll do
it November we'll do 500 quid for
charity for the IDF the Israeli Defense
Force or right if if if if I could do it
you pay 500 to the immune deficiency
Foundation sure if I fail I'll pay 500.
take on it on camera right now
probably around that time it's probably
around that time it's around this
episode is coming out right now as we're
recording this it is the 8th of
September yes so you have about two and
a half months yeah you have two and a
half months so by the time this episode
comes out it will be very very close to
the deadline 100 pound dollars whatever
you'll be fine let's make it
because I want to do it in the flesh
right I don't want to be like send you a
photo because I can do it in the flesh
yeah it's two months in like two thirds
yeah two months and like three weeks but
what does this yeah like like
how deep does it need to be it has to be
uh you have to be able to distinguish
the muscles yeah if we can clearly see
six things yeah then that's a six-pack
yeah easy cut okay all right there we go
there it is
either way it's a win for ADF so yeah I
have no choice I have to get a six-pack
probably that I have to because I have
to because phase three of the [ __ ]
silly ridiculous weight loss challenge
is doing chess boxing match for Ludwig
in Los Angeles
that's where you are Thanos you know so
I've got a this chest box match thing
yeah which I'm still trying to wrap my
head around you have a round of chest in
the boxing room yes uh for two minutes
yep yeah and then and then you've just
brought away and you're like right now
let's [ __ ] go Rocky Balboa yeah and
then two [ __ ] minutes beat the [ __ ]
out of each other they're back to chest
and back to chest and then is it it's
it's either whoever gets a KO first or
whoever gets a Checkmate first yeah I'm
worried I'm gonna travel all the way to
Los Angeles and get checkmate like three
moves
[Applause]
I can play chess probably to an
intermediate level I don't know how I
compare to you guys who's the bet you're
the best right Gump
okay okay from like public track record
yes I'm the best apparently she's the
worst probably probably Joey what level
are you well I learned how to play from
the chest yeah what's your chest.com
never even touched the chessboard but I
only started chess.com like a month ago
what's your rating on that brilliant
how do you find out your rating your
numbers
you go on your profile picture and if
you've been playing chess these these
should have a number next to it but if
I've only been playing a month well it's
still yeah yeah yeah yeah even after
like one match it'll tell you the number
yeah because you start off with a number
stats you are
do you know if he's been training a lot
for the boxing I don't know that though
oh what if he's been trained like a
madman yeah well let's hope not let's
hope not but I what if what if there's
just one guy who's just been putting all
of his training into like the chess I'm
not into like the boxing I've run away
yeah just run away right that's a
legitimate strategy yeah right I almost
wish it was just a pure boxing match in
some respect because he could just focus
on that one thing you have to focus on
two sort of one mentally challenging one
physically challenging I think that's
the whole point of one minute
to wonder where the event will lean more
is it more for the comical aspect of it
or is it more for the serious like
boxing sport Ludwig has instructed us to
take it very seriously yes it's not like
a joke I don't think it's just is the
what's the one yeah I don't know if it's
as mentally serious as that that was
sanctioned by the boxing like yeah well
this is sanctioned by the chess boxing
Federation
but it's you know it's still very
serious and stuff oh yeah I'm taking it
deadly seriously and I have been
training a little bit with boxing but I
need to ramp that up soon the main thing
is before you even start boxing I need
to just get fit because it just it just
takes it out of you when you're punching
and you know yeah like one Boxing class
and I my body was ruined yeah yeah and
so by doing the cycle and the Spartan
Race and a few other things I'm sort of
building up to it as well yeah
um but yeah my aim this year I got a
really bad like Health Report in the
middle of this year cholesterol very bad
and your blood levels rubbish and your
blood pressure [ __ ] it's just like
nothing nothing was good yeah the doctor
was like your kidneys my liver was like
really bad and he's like you must drink
a lot I'm like not really
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah because we were going on tour and
we're just like let's uh let's delay it
let's see if we can delay it and they
say yes uh mostly because like our
health exam was meant to be just after
we came back from America and I think we
just like we we just we didn't want to
see it to the hospital uh you're dead
but now it's instead it's when we come
back from America so yeah yeah you're
gonna your health approach's gonna be an
atrocity oh yeah yeah if you fought in a
war recently right what's happened to
yourself have you been carb loading
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or Computer Guys how do you
feel about shopping online love it can't
stop with it do it all the time I mean
do you even go to physical stores
anymore no no not really but considering
how often that is how many times you
actually have a promo code ready to go
at the checkout
ever well thanks to Hardy manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past oh my God we are reaching the
future ladies and gentlemen honey is the
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your cars Connor
what did you save money on with honey I
use honey to save about 15 on some brand
new lenses we bought well guess what
guys honey doesn't just work on desktop
it works on
you can already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
guys missing out am I getting here
you're not just stealing yourself a
favor are you helping us out too so get
honey for free by going to joinhoney.com
trash taste that's joinhoney.com trash
taste links in the description below
back to the episode you know I this year
for some reason I I just lost a lot of
motivation uh sometime around April a
few things went wrong after right the
chemother thing came out the documentary
I was very happy on a high yeah and then
the earthquake came and knocked down the
studio and I was like ah [ __ ] and then I
went on journey across Japan which is a
[ __ ] nightmare to shoot yeah and I
ruptured my eardrums and got heat stroke
every single day
some water sports and I I came off the
site into the water like that yeah like
just blue it was amazing because we
didn't I wish I had filmed my POV of it
because it was Chris and um and real
tarot on the on the back of this boat oh
no no I wasn't asking sorry it was it
was Chris and Nancy on the back of
speedboat this thing was probably like
the truth the centrifugal force was
probably like it's going out late so
they're using NASA to like launch people
into [ __ ] space I reckon you were
going at like at least 60 70. the
problem was that's you know with this
competition it was one of these things
we hold on to the back of a rubber ring
yeah and it's being tugged around yeah
and uh natsuki and I were against Jerry
and ryotaro yeah we weren't doing very
well but we were like we're gonna nail
this one yeah and we held on really long
and did really well and this guy he must
have been like in the Yakuza or
something this was a really shady outfit
during these water sports he was like
Max Speed 100 and he [ __ ] took us
around the corner and I I knew I was
like if I fall off like I don't really
get brain damage yeah it was so fun and
and I remember just the moment Chris let
go of the Ring yeah it was like he he
actually tumbled on the surface of the
wall oh my God it was like falling off a
vehicle yeah it was really bad and you
know it's just like flew across the like
a skipping he just flew across the
surface I'm just like holy [ __ ]
it's like imagine getting like a
screwdriver and ramming it down your ear
just like that and then the pain was an
unimaginable and I had to like not pass
out in the water because but then we
took Chris to go see a uh in ear and eye
specialist because there was one in
ishigaki that just happened to speak
English as well we're like great let's
go to that right and I remember because
you know I was sitting there doing the
translation thing right and uh you know
they'd put the camera inside Chris is
here and I'm just like oh my god there
was an actual [ __ ] hole there's a
hole it's just a straight up hole in his
eardrum I'm like
he's deaf but he's just like there's no
recovery from that oh it was really bad
I was deaf in my right ear for like a
month and a half but then the guy was
like you are okay
well you can recover from that you can
you're here it eventually recovers I was
scared about flying on the plane
right happening but it was like no
problem there's a hole in your ear so
depression goes straight through I was
like yeah the plane wasn't too bad yeah
and it was literally just like here's
some painkillers so you had the UK trip
a month later yeah and the the hole
started to heal
um I could start hearing again but the
doctor that I saw and said I was like oh
it's very you know you went because your
ear is still kind of sensitive it could
just explode on the flight yeah precious
sort of builds up right yeah so that was
really unpleasant so the build up to the
flight to the UK I don't like flying
yeah I was gonna say you don't like
flying anyway right
knowing half your head's gonna explode
mid-flight and there's gonna trap
everywhere like it was just like oh no
kill me and so I had this like
succession of bad things happen right
yeah and then right at the end of that
it was like here's a Health Report just
to [ __ ] kick him while you're down I
was like no my blood pressure and
everything's really bad so UK you won't
have as well yeah you just did not hold
that I did go handling every single time
I saw Chris it was like dessert a cheese
board
again oh my God that restaurant we had
two oh the blooming's already Chris was
just like help me please help me with
this board and we're all like no no no
how much Camembert would you like so I'm
not [ __ ] as well that restaurant when
you you mugged me off so you know we're
gonna go meet at this restaurant this
really fancy uh what's the name of the
chef Essence
I don't give a [ __ ] but Chris loves
these restaurants
and so I get there first and I'm I'm
like messaging Chris I'm like I don't
know what's what's the resolution what's
the reservation name because I'm like
what did you put it on though is it your
name your friend's name yeah like whose
name is
so he replies with the name Barry
chopsticks
right
sarcastic I was like what do you
thinking
literally just Barry Chopsticks via text
got nothing to go off right and so I
think this is like him [ __ ] with me
right so I message him I'm like What's
it really under he sees it 10 minutes
goes by doesn't reply and I'm waiting
outside I'm like I want to [ __ ] go in
the restaurant
so I go in I go into this really it's in
the Mandarin Oriental Hotel in London
it's like this ridiculously fancy hope
there's literally like like the Queen's
guards outside this hotel it's
ridiculous and if you go in there and
you look even remotely poor they're like
no no yeah like they're just like so I'm
going in there and I'm like yeah I have
a restaurant reservation so they let me
in they go into this ridiculous Lobby
which looks like you know the British
museum stolen artifact yeah or combined
and then you go up here and there's
another desk and I'm like oh I have a
restaurant reservation for Barrow
chopsticks
[Laughter]
and they're like they're looking they're
looking they're looking and they go yep
go right ahead
so then I'm like oh this [ __ ]
actually put it under Berry Chopsticks
so then I'm walking into the we're
walking through this hotel which is like
just again it's like the most Immaculate
I have like five armed guards supporting
me and they all look like Butlers and
stuff and it's ridiculous I go to this
other place again I'm dressed in like
I'm sweating it was so hot in the UK
sweaty I look gross I like wearing jeans
I go to this other guy and uh we're
finally at the front of a restaurant I'm
like oh that wasn't the actual like
thing to get in the rest
they have a reception for the reception
they have a reception for the reception
okay and then this guy really like you
know fancy and uh he's like obviously
reservation name and I go once again I'm
like I'm not confident this time now
because I got through the first time
yeah it's under Barry Chopsticks
so so then he he he looks at me like
starts looking over the list and he's
like
um we don't have a reservation for Barry
Chopsticks and I'm like oh and he's like
but we do have a reservation for Chris
broad are you friends with Chris Broad
and I was like how the [ __ ] do you know
that I'm it's Chris broad is Barry
Chopsticks
generally he was like are you friends
with Chris Ward yeah I was like yes and
he's like oh very well this way and I
was like what the [ __ ] just happened and
I'm texting Christmas you're an [ __ ]
you're actually an [ __ ] you're a
giant dick Chris and I we were traveling
in the same taxi together it's a
restaurant we're just [ __ ] losing it
in the back of this taxi
clearly the guy knows that it was Chris
Broad and must have recognized me
what if he did what if it was just like
a random guy who just said didn't have a
booking and you're just like are you
friends with Chris praud why would you
ask that but you must have known that it
was Chris Broad and that I turned up
yeah thank God there was no one that had
a reservation actually called Barry
chops
yeah so then the guy probably just
thought I was like some racist or
something
but I was like I was like what why why
would you tell me that name and then at
no point he's
he's replied to me and tell me the
actual name except what I thought it was
that Chris was trying to be like some
like he thought he was too famous or
something Paparazzi no I can't let them
know my real names
that's what I thought was going on
crystal he was too big and then he had
to have a name it's sarcastic oh so
funny I'm definitely making restaurant
reservations
that's just my Alias from now that's
that's the highlight of my trip
so expensive he's so funny yeah this was
a two-star Michelin restaurant as well
how did you went to the restaurant and
ordered from the alacar menu
remember the set menu the like of course
me look [ __ ] yeah it looked awful it
sounded Dreadful it was also a bit
overpriced as well it was a two-star
mission of course it's overpriced I
think it was overpriced yeah like I was
like that's a gift of course Chris broad
is here Five Guys it was
the menu all the mains or like a hundred
dollars and I was like oh my word they
were like 60 pounds
I don't know what it is about fancy
restaurants all the starters are always
better meat fruit though yeah I feel
like because with those fancy
restaurants they really have to like
just pack so much into like the entrees
and the appetizers because it's like a
smaller course it was like this pate
covered in like in the shape of an
orange in a mandarin it looks like yeah
I didn't like the orange pop
the Pate was amazing and they gave you
so much and they gave you unlimited
thick bread as well and we all got full
off the bread before them
[Music]
honestly it sucks to say the bread is
better than the main the bread which
probably was yeah the bread was really
good but that's what you do at fancy
restaurants you just get fill up fill up
on the bread it was insane yeah it was
so good and then Chris got this uh
cheese board for dessert and he got it
like every single time went out cheese
board but this cheeseboard was
ridiculous it was just massive and Chris
was full and then he's just looking at
us like saving different types of cheese
he's like what's the what's the Matilda
guy called again
Brucey you never tell them what he's
like shoving the chocolate cake in his
mouth
Chris just shoving this cheese in his
mouth like crying nobody want to slice
his shoes
oh my Lord what a trip that was yeah
that was so funny you're the first
person I've met who actually orders
cheese for desserts for desserts yeah
because like like cheese is just like is
I it's like to me ordering cheeses
dessert for desserts like ordering
another main it's like yeah it's so I
feel it's so filling by itself like
sometimes I just share as good fruit is
it yeah
people mentioned this during our live
show we did everyone was like Chris
seems actually happy he likes life yeah
Chris is really energetic and happy
about being in the UK I mean yeah yeah
the first half of this year I was not
myself really I just I wasn't yeah happy
and uh yeah you know I think it's just
not going home seeing family for all
that time does that and Japan is great
but it can weigh you down and yeah
there's lots of things that can bug you
and you need to leave the country once
every year or twice a year preferable
yeah so and I didn't do that for three
years yeah my family and I think there
was a lot of mounting anxiety and
pressure about that yeah and that's why
I ate all the cheese
that's the main reasons
did you notice anything different about
the UK this time that you went back
nothing works so nothing works
everyone's on strike constantly now
what's that the day the day we went to
this luxurious restaurant with Barry
Chopstick like we the [ __ ] trains
went there because yeah Jerry and I had
to like battle our way through London
I was really angry and Conor was like
what was the name under I was like oh
you think he's under Chopsticks so and
every time I went to London there was a
there was a strike of some sort yeah
yeah I'm all four strikes just not when
I'm there
Chris is coming into town
I went to London maybe three times and
yeah I I was very unlucky every time was
the time I was going in I I've had such
bad experiences with cab drivers uh with
like Uber drivers and stuff in London
that I actually got a black cab one time
yeah official London Camp I was like uh
can you take me here and now I was like
you say yeah I was like do you know like
where that is and he looked at me he's
like
it's like you know I'm a London cab
driver right of course I know what that
is and then I was like all right okay
all right
obviously he knew yeah I was just like
all right sorry mate I was just making
sure because I thought it may be a
little specific I don't know that's how
you know you're too used to Japanese
characters because Japanese because they
never know where you're going well
that's that's why I like London like
there was like this big strike with like
London black cab drivers when Uber first
got launched because you have to go
through like a rigorous set of
qualifications to get like your black
cab license yeah like know the streets
no London in and out and then off up
comes Uber and the [ __ ] technology
with GPS and suddenly that knowledge is
useless now well not useless but it's
completely unfair to the black cab
drivers yeah it sucks though because
it's like you know when I when I lived
in London it was just Uber but now
there's like four uh like giant like uh
what are they cab ride chat one of the
[ __ ] Rideshare companies yeah I can't
call them a cab company
and they all drove all the prices down
yeah of like because Uber used to be
really expensive but just in terms of
getting a normal cap but that bolts and
stuff and all the other companies it's
ridiculously cheap to get a cab now in
London with one of these apps so you
know it's hard to get people to be like
yeah we should we should keep the cabs
but also I really don't want to pay 50
pound for a 20 minute Journey I'd rather
be 20 pounds yeah it's kind of it's hard
to you know get people on board with it
when they're like I like I like cheaper
cabs but I feel like part of it is due
to the fact that London is such like a
heavily tourist country
yeah black cabs are just I guess like
part of that experience I mean that's
the only I can't think of any other
reasons they would choose to keep the
[ __ ] red phone boxes because they all
smell of piss like you go to London no
no [ __ ] London I go for ghosts take a
Pedro I realize all my friends want to
take a picture of the red uh the boxes
like all of them looked really bad and
they were like is there going to be one
that doesn't look bad like
five percent chance yeah that's good
that's probably in a closed off area
like maybe
yeah because I remember first time
Sydney went to the UK when she moved
here she was like so excited to see one
of the red like phone boxes she was like
oh my God it's one of the red phone
boxes oh my god get your phone out we're
gonna take a picture right now she
[ __ ] bolts in opens the door rushes
in picks up the phone box oh then as
soon as she does she just gets hit with
this wave of smell and she's just like
there's just a picture of Justin with a
phone watch you go
I was like her first experience
you've landed in the UK
yeah but some other days it was really
really busy and I was just like oh this
is [ __ ] did this IRL stream on Connor's
Channel obviously yeah down the Thames
and we stopped this restaurant this guy
came over with this really nice like toy
doll what was it it was a John no
Giovanna pen and he tried to give it to
you at the like the trash taste London
event right right yeah and he's like I
couldn't make it and what a coincidence
I've just run into you here definitely
not stream sniping you anyway he gave
kind of this toy yeah
thank you very much away with your
peasants and the guys
and then we're still in the Stream and
Connor just went uh just broke it there
and there
on the floor not on purpose and then the
chat was like oh my God you're awful and
then the guy just happened to come back
he was like oh my God you've broken the
presence
really weird situation yeah you live
London Queen
[Music]
how has your like Excel London event
where the guy came up on stage that
looked fun that's one of the harder ones
that was uh that was a learning
experience yeah
um I mean you never know how you're
going to act in that kind of situation
until that kind of happens I guess and I
guess we learn a lot about trash taste
and we learned a lot about ourselves as
well I was just a deer in the headlights
the entirely yeah like completely out of
it you were kind of quiet and you were
like you know you've got your favorite
school teacher you don't want to
disappoint and then they lecture you
that's what it was like okay mate you've
heard your fun games
you're like your favorite teachers just
like told you off okay because because
like I was prepared to throw hands but I
wanted to like de-escalate the situation
before so I think I just wanted to like
disappointed parents mode right yeah
because like before you throw hands you
like to me when I hear like the
disappointed voice that hits me harder
than if someone's like screaming or
shouting at me because like oh [ __ ] I've
done something wrong guys I'm sorry sir
did not mean anything no words did not
mean anything to that guy yeah but also
we should never have been in a situation
where we even had to consider throwing
hands yeah but we spoke about that and
security was terrible until it wasn't
yeah they sorted that out real quick
exactly The Bodyguard no one threw
themselves
from SAS yeah I yeah I love there's a
clip of you at the one in Los Angeles
what was the event called Anime Expo
yeah yeah and you're like walking with
like a [ __ ] Army of men
it's like I used to be able to relate to
Sea Dogs
private Jeff Bezos
[ __ ] 300 when you walked into that
event and the videos you're like what
happened someone down a hole Yeah I mean
we didn't we we wanted security for that
we didn't say hey we want 10. but I
think they just kept sporty they were
like I think what happened was it's
almost like we need more people because
yeah this is too much we need more I I
think MCA yeah I think MCM set a
standard and everyone saw that or all
the conventions all that because all the
conventions that we went to referred to
that like incident to be like we don't
want to repeat of that how come you
don't do conventions
I I'm doing an event in London when I go
back like Anime conventions or something
I'm sure you get invited about it I
don't know anything about anime would
you would you go to YouTube
people always answer like when does
Chris come on I don't [ __ ] know it
because
nobody invites me I only got invite I
did get invited to one this year Japan
was uh Japan Expo where the Japan Expo
there's the the UK one as well I can't
remember what that's called I think if
I'd been invited to the one you guys
went to I'd have been like yeah I'll go
really yeah MCM yeah yeah I've been
invited to one called an amazement in
North Korea oh yeah yeah which is like a
that's like an anime slash like Japan
yeah I got invited one in hyper Japan
that's the one in the UK Japan hyper
Japan I'd do that if they invited me I
don't think I've invited me before but
no The Price is Right of course if the
camembert's there
they just leave trails
[Applause]
if it's a Japan one then probably I
could do it but anime what can I talk
about again you don't I love Akira yeah
yeah you don't talk they you just sit
there and sign autographs where's the
fun in that
me you get to meet your fans I do want
to meet my my family I got this um
because I haven't been back to the UK at
Christmas Chris is my favorite time of
year I've got this event in London that
I'm doing and it's gonna do like 500
people there and I'll you know meet them
there that'll be fun have you ever done
like a public event where you get to
like meet your like viewers and fans and
everything like that yeah we did that
first journey across Japan I did one
after generic across Japan and I feel
like I did another one that I've
forgotten class I guess the short answer
yeah I did I did some stuff for TC but
like no I I'm all for it I've got a
Halloween event as well excited YouTube
but you're going to be in Wisconsin so
yeah or somewhere in the far flung now
we'll be in Portland yeah yeah so I've
got like a Halloween event meet up thing
that's coming up so I've got like two
events yeah in Japan nice so I'm doing
some stuff but no like yeah I'd I'd be
up for doing a convention yeah
opportunities there The Price is Right
have you ever signed anything before or
fans and everything like that yeah it's
usually the photos though isn't it yeah
yeah I had a guy in Don Quixote like the
mega Don Quixote and Shibu wants to come
up to me and he wanted the signature and
I was filming a TC video doing something
and I was like if you've got a pen he
was like no I was like how's this going
to work then
spent five to ten minutes walking around
Don Quixote amidst a shoot I was doing
trying to find a pin so I could sign
something for this guy yeah he was a
little bit rude like most people are
nice this guy wasn't and uh I was not
watching but we found a pen and I was
like okay we've got the pen let's let's
get this sign what do you want to sign
he's like actually can't just take a
photo
that's why I don't do signings
yeah we literally one of this like
Indiana Jones fetch quest to get a
[ __ ] pet for nothing yeah you
searched for it yeah why did you say it
was being nice I was like I'll find this
pen we'll get the signature you should
just be like oh you got a pen and then I
don't know why after this like Adventure
he flipped and was ah you know let's
just have a photo yeah he did and he had
his 10 minutes of fun so that was all
tactical see because like yeah he just
wanted to spend time with you being like
yes I don't have a yeah but yeah I mean
I did this when I did this TC event
after journey across Japan one we had
about 100 people there and I I spent an
hour I think I spoke to every single
person yeah and I I enjoy it yeah
meeting people so did you use uh did you
have to make up a signature on the spot
yeah do you have a signature my
signature in it do I have a signature no
like I don't know do you have enough
yeah do you have an Abra in Japan
signature yeah Japan's signature
it's just like a variation of
um my real signature oh I've seen it
because 10 000 people have tagged me
every time someone gets an aparri shirt
so you've got more dripping
literally I don't know how many shirts
you've sold it must be a billion because
every [ __ ] day for the last three
months it's like you've got more driven
Krishna because every time you get a
share that is the thing it says I don't
know who signed off on this I'm gonna
have one of you killed
taken for granted because we because
three of us three of us are three
different messages and it gets
randomized next time we'll provide three
different messages to Chris when we uh
launch an experts every every shirt you
sell I get tagged again
no no so I've seen your signature a few
times are you not worried about having
your real signature helper uh is that
something you need to worry about well I
mean signature or anything like people
we're gonna start cashing checks
if someone if they happen to like grab
your bank information they could easily
sign off on it if they know what your
signature
there's nothing I've not done a
convention because a thousand people my
signature exactly I remember ax
um we were doing signings together and
then this was the first year obviously
we had like trash taste like convention
and then someone saw mail in the
background and they asked for her
signature and malin's like never signed
anything in her life and so we call her
over she excitedly you know excited to
get her to sign her first thing and then
as she starts she puts the pen down and
I go mail in do not put your real
signature down yeah yeah this is this is
make up a fake signature and then she
puts the pen down and I'm like I said
that I didn't I like crashed her for
like five minutes I think she was like
and your security
down there's three magic numbers
[Laughter]
Jesus I remember Pete Premiere too did a
twitch stream once and showed off my
business card with my phone number and I
was like you [ __ ] guy I'm gonna have
you kill Pete like took down the stream
it's very kind of would be fair
I know yeah you should probably make up
a new signature what would it be Japan
yeah come on how did you make a camera
Barry Chopsticks
and BC my initials reversed
[Laughter]
broad Chris that's the broad stain all
right I'll remember that yeah no I would
say yes to a convention if the if the
opportunity right and the price is right
and the price was right yeah okay in
America or UK or anywhere yeah I'd like
to do it so I actually turned one down
in Italy oh just because I just come out
from the UK and I didn't want to go all
the way to Europe what kind of
convention was it like uh Japan was it
Japan anime convention I can't remember
the entire name of it and um I thought I
thought about it yeah Freehold it Italy
it was but then I was like but then I
have to probably go to the UK and see my
family and friends
[Laughter]
it was literally [ __ ] it was awful the
ass is not fair yeah well why is it not
fair wait I remember I had a much better
time than I did so I don't want to hear
it I remember I got I disappointed uh an
old man though I made him lose his face
in the Youth of today
drone incident remember what do you
remember oh yeah so you know Chris wants
to get these drone shots so we're
getting these drone shots and this
country field near the church area yeah
and um yeah so we're just driving and
then Chris wants to get his drone back
so we pull up into this like really dirt
road opposite someone's house yeah
drone's coming down and if you if you
know anything about like rural UK people
are very nosy right when something
happens near their land yeah they they
tend to be like you know on the ball
especially older people yeah because
it's like they know everything that
happens yeah yeah they do not miss it
and I I thought oh my god when Chris is
pulling out putting the Drone down so
someone's out of house I was like oh
they're going to come out I know they're
going to come out so the Drone comes
down into the thing and I grab it and
put it in the car and as you're coming
out this older gentleman comes down and
basically like Flags us down right so
Chris you know had two choices stop or
just go off yeah so Chris decided to
stop gentlemen yeah yeah so then
um the the guy you know he's like is
that your drone that just went into that
field and Christopher's like you could
see the decision in Chris's head of like
do I lie do I tell the truth I lied to
me so he lied he said no it wasn't my
drone I don't know and he's like oh
because you know like he went in that
field and uh you know I hope that
something hasn't happened to her yeah
and then Chris is like oh I lied yet it
was my drone
[Laughter]
I lied it wasn't
the guy looked so disappointed the guy
like it was like his son had just told
him he'd lie that's the exact way you
admit to your parents as well you know
like like sorry Mom I did lie I did do
it okay then well it's really awkward
and really just a Christian it was just
like two awkward people talking to each
other I'm just sitting there crying in
the corner laughing well they're just
like well then yes
by the way there's a beautiful view up
here it was just like class cringing it
was like out of here I thought he would
be like why are you flying a drone I I
don't know what people in the UK think
of drones it's my first time and I was
like [ __ ] is he gonna report me the
police or something yeah yeah
I don't know why I then went uh it was
my drone I lied I should have reworded
that like oh that drone yeah that was
mine because the two are true
I said like I don't know why I literally
said oh
and so then Chris felt bad immediately
and then back pedaled which yeah in the
worst way his faith in the Youth of
today
I'm not talking to someone you could
tell that guy wasn't out for blood you
know because some people come out and
the you know the first thing they say is
they got a chip on their shoulder yeah
they're just ready to fight whoever did
that yeah he didn't seem like that yeah
but you know Chris likes it's like Chris
and now he's gonna be that kind of guy
the next one now that guy's not gonna
trust people yeah the moral of the story
of this episode of trash taste never
lying yeah don't lie guys don't yeah so
you know people ask me that like did you
actually have a five-star hotel booked I
did that night and then Chris dragged me
to this [ __ ] Church
it's awful that's fun on it everyone
that comes like whoa a church but
obviously being raised in like the UK
yeah you see churches all the time so we
I was like I don't I want to stay in a
church by being a kid again I hated
going to church as a kid I basically I'd
run out of ideas right on this trip to
the UK I need to do a video because I
had nothing planned I was like a wacky
weekend and because it was the Queen's
Jubilee everything good was literally
sold out or take it right yeah yeah so I
don't know how we found it but there was
a church and I was like that'll do [ __ ]
it let's go there and [ __ ] it [ __ ] it it
was awful but the there was a really
good Pub next to it and really really
nice actually but it was really I mean I
I don't believe in ghost but it was
quite unsettling staying in a church I
wake up at 3am and you're just in this
Pulpit of a church and you just hear
like creaking and like
I was they provided there's a hot water
bottle to fill up and I was like well
I'm using it Chris thought I was like
dumb he's like making fun of me being
like hot water while it's hot today and
I was like right we'll see at night and
then in the morning he wakes up like
shivering going I should have used the
hood and I was like yeah you should have
it was a really weird two-day because
and then we stayed in this prison yeah I
saw you guys stayed in the prison
couldn't convince me to do the prison I
was like no not doing the president I
thought it was going to be a lot more
pleasant than it actually was it turned
out halfway through the toilet someone
had like killed themselves in our cell
they'd like put a rope around there yeah
he was like it was that was it was
telling like a ghost story you know
about like a prisoner that had gone
insane and he was like by the way who's
still saying in cell number nine and
we're like
uh that's one of the most active cells
yeah it's like that's one of the most
active cells a guy hanged himself there
and I'm like good I remember thank you
waking up in the middle of the night I'm
always trying to wake up at 3am when I
stay somewhere haunted a weird yeah woke
up and Joey's on the floor like
I don't know how I feel and I was
looking at the window thinking oh my God
this is really unpleasant in a cell and
I and I thought when I booked this stay
in the prison night experience In
fairness it was the cheapest wacky
weekend I've ever shot because the
church was 100 quids the prison was 100
quid yeah so good cheap accommodation if
you want to stay for cheap in the UK yes
stay in a literal prison I thought
there'd be like a bed in the prison cell
there was no bed there was expecting
like a five-star Mission
he wanted he wanted a massage
I thought there would be something
I can understand if they were offering
to stay in a prison that they might have
like something yeah we had this lattice
metal thing that you put a mattress son
yeah that was it and then the floor it
looked like a cheese grater
did you bring like a sleeping bag or
something yeah like the thinnest [ __ ]
Amazon basic sleeping we were using the
one that I used the night before
probably yeah because I think the the
champagne as it's called Church camping
oh originally I think the booking
initially had a bed in it right but then
they removed it because of covet yes and
then they were like you have to bring
your receiving bags now it was like what
it's like could you imagine a normal
Hotel yeah
you have to bring your own to the hotel
the mattress is soaked and covered it's
just like what I I didn't really get it
it was it was just uncomfortable the
church it wasn't very fast yeah it was
just cold and [ __ ] also cringy yeah also
Chris and I had this weird thing on the
drive to uh the prison where we just
like found a bunch of really weird named
English towns I don't even loving it
because Joey's before this you've been
the UK once or twice before once and we
never we talked about about the UK [ __ ]
mate there's a lot nothing there because
Connor gave him a tour of like Croydon
and that was it because I was like I'm
gonna give Joey the best tour and a
prison cell yeah take your match with
Australian Roots but I'd only ever I've
only ever been in like London for a few
days yeah and that's my whole experience
the prison was in a really nice place
near him bath right yeah we're driving
there and Joseph look at his family
Nutley and all these like weird obscure
names like crap crap crap
down the force and he's like man this is
so funny it might be like a [ __ ]
stupid name it's ridiculous look at
Australian Town names and laugh this is
how I feel yeah Joey Joey had a whale of
a time yeah and I was like we have to go
to kravnell yeah so we actually took a
detour nothing incredible 7 A.M after
this prison drove to crap now it's just
a farm that was literally crap and it
was just oh that's that's why it's
called crap surely right awful but yeah
that's the UK in it yeah yeah to be fair
though it was like once we were actually
out of London and you know in the
National Countryside it was very very
nice the UK is good yeah I really
enjoyed it what do you think Stonehenge
it's there almost underwhelming place
because people ruined it for us you used
to be able to go upstairs yeah I wish I
would yeah I feel like it would have
been a lot cooler if I were is it one of
like the seven world wonders or
something like that this might be it
yeah what the [ __ ] is wonderful about it
that's pretty expensive like it is it's
not wondrous at all isn't it wondrous
because they're wondering how the [ __ ]
they made it because they have no idea
how they made it or where they got the
stones from or something all right uh I
don't know how they carry the stones
yeah how they would have been able to
place the stones like that thousands of
years ago yeah all I know is it was more
expensive than that Michelin star
restaurant to go and look at it you get
to the door and it's like five thousand
five it's like five thousand yen each
yeah
like a little Stonehenge thing because
I'm like that because you know we
collect knickknacks from all over the
world and I was just like it's just like
70 quid for [ __ ] knickknack of
Stonehenge I'm like no that's stupid who
the [ __ ] is playing for 70 quit it was
like it was it was it was actually like
stupid
anything different about the UK there
when you were there
um
honestly I thought there was I don't
know maybe it's just where I was living
but there was definitely like a lot more
food options I thought like the food
option and just the free India the food
quality in general in the UK was just
like a lot better oh God yeah everyone
like clowns on like UK Cuisine yeah you
know yeah yeah rightly so in some senses
but in this on this trip back most of
the restaurants I went to were actually
like yeah they're really good really bad
I mean most people mocking the UK
feudish Americans who've never left
America so you know or Japanese I don't
Japanese people and British food really
annoys me they're like oh your food very
bad I'm like have you been they're like
no I'm like [ __ ] go there eat the
fish and chips see the shepherd's pie
devour them covering like go and enjoy
it and then like rank it and rate it
yeah I find British food is really good
particularly pub food there's a reason I
put on four kilograms in the three of
them's really good carb loading I carve
loaded the [ __ ] out I can't load on beer
oh bro I just go to town yeah the UK is
good but I did reach a point first two
weeks I was like why would anyone not
want to live here it's amazing it's
magical yeah things weighed me down like
you know things going wrong I mean a lot
of things don't work in the UK yeah
like an Airbnb and then the shower just
didn't work well I don't ever be in the
UK yeah I've had so many Horrors Airbnb
and hotels I don't know hotels in the UK
what hotels are pretty good in the UK
they are you're not even paying like an
exclusion anymore you don't even get a
[ __ ] toothbrush
I thought that was weird no that's the
same all over the world it's just Japan
and a few other countries amenity wise
because they most countries I go to
America Thailand I'm sure most American
hotels don't give you toothbrushes
really think about when we were when we
were in America at the hotel we stayed
and didn't give us a toothbrush
Australia gave us two friends
basically every like every country is
the knot don't give toothbrushes because
it's bad for the environment to just
give a disposable toothbrush every time
it's a lot of plastic and also like a
lot of hotels I think reuse soap not
like in the they like take it and then
mash it all down okay right right which
is good I I understand like okay I I
love the convenience of the toothbrush
at the hotel but I get it that it it is
just a waste like you can just bring
your own because you're bringing your
own
medicine or uh why did you spill it up
you just spill it on your eye
like do you really need a toothbrush at
the hotel because you're probably
bringing a bag of amenities anyway right
yes I do most of the time because if if
like England had more convenience stores
like Japan I wouldn't mind this much do
you bring your own amenities I forget
all the time
that's because I bring them now because
I'm just used to it the thing is most
hotels that don't Supply toothbrushes if
you call up the front desk
yeah you forgot mine they'll be like yes
yeah in like in like more expensive ones
but it's I don't know it's like
travelodges do it yeah but like it's
[ __ ] men look size isn't it yeah I
don't know what I'm saying is like it
save the planet I know come on I said we
don't need the [ __ ] toothbrushes we
just bring your own
the hotel in Australia had the wooden
toothbrushes yeah exactly so did the uh
yeah exactly yeah there's ways around
that one too [ __ ] I the one thing pissed
me off about Japan right let's say I
just want more toothpaste than any
Supply I have to go and get more
toothbrushes because they only slide
them in oh yeah that's it right you get
toothbrush and toothpaste so I wanted I
had brought my own toothbrush but I I
wanted toothpaste so I had to get like
three toothbrushes and just bend three
toothbrushes to get the toothpaste I
wanted which felt really bad because I'm
like great I just threw a three
perfectly good toothbrushes because they
didn't give me the option why would you
not just go to a community just get some
toothpaste I feel like the trash
toothbrush let's see there's a new
plushie let's make some money I think
the the final straw at my time like in
the UK was just one of my last days just
one of the ATMs I use every day I just
watch the guy just piss on it at night
all over it and I was just like what is
this like [ __ ] capitalists yeah I was
just like oh don't really usual
cashmer I barely used cash money no it's
like an advertising campaign against you
genuinely after I mean I I don't I don't
I I didn't use any cash in the UK or
America it's just a tap now yeah it's so
good so it's so convenient a thousand
pounds drain from your account instantly
yeah oh my God it's amazing well
certainly not be using cash on that ATM
anymore but just like people just
respecting the just the public space I
kind of I Like the Way in Japan people
are really good about taking care of
their surroundings yeah yeah yeah we
don't in the UK I think that's a real
problem well a lot of countries don't do
that I think it's Japan is the weird one
in that sense
this much about taking care of this
space things just work it's very
convenient yeah I mean I love the UK
it's just like when you go back there
for a long time a lot of little things
just build up and build up and you get
reminded oh okay this is why I moved out
in the first place yeah I saw you into a
Cornwall as well yeah that was nice yeah
almost beautiful like yeah felt like a
different country I always wanted to go
there and yeah to drive there yeah
we're gonna get to Japan
is such a goddamn pain together
London Beyond Nutley and crap no there's
a place right right right in the corner
like right in the bottom left corner
very very nice place though yeah staying
like these really beautiful picturesque
fishing towns and things had like a real
pasty for the first time that was good
nice
um yeah I went to Cornwall because uh my
UK mates took me there for my UK stag do
and uh that's where I have my stag
um yeah and we went there was my first
time in Cornwall [ __ ] beautiful
weather we tried surfing for the first
time and I was just like this is I can't
believe I'm doing this in the UK also
surfing [ __ ] hard
my balancing on water was going to be
easy balancing on water okay I didn't
realize you needed that much you know
upper body strength right
for some reason I just thought okay so I
think it's all about keeping the balance
and you know you know being able to swim
being a strong swim and stuff like that
what I didn't take into account is you
know to get up when you're bored you
have to do like a push-up on water every
time yeah and like by the end of my
first surfing session my like my my arms
were jelly like my legs and everything
were fine it was like my arms I gave out
first were you able to master at some
degree I was able to stand up my
surfboard it was one of the most it was
it was so like just satisfying to like
do that because have you ever been
surfing before no no I kind of like to
do it but yeah yeah again I don't know
special trash it's a lot of fun
yeah probably really interesting yeah
what about swimming Cornwall
um it's not really that big is it it's
I'd give surfing a try yeah oh my God I
would kill the sea one so I would love
to see you think I want to stand up
just [ __ ] like like this understand
[ __ ] it was I what was it
was just like this it's like I'm
standing up guys unbelievable
unbelievable how long how many hours it
take you to get from like scratch to
being good honestly we were just there
for like one day and I wouldn't say I
was good but by the end of like the
first session I was able to stand up on
the surfboards which is like a decent
decent amount of time literally right
rode the wave along yeah yeah so you you
uh you catch the wave and you rode it to
the end it wasn't like a big wave it was
just like a little baby wave because we
couldn't go too deep in and I think
actually like it takes more effort as a
beginner I think it's like similar to
snowboarding or something where it takes
more effort to learn it as a beginner
because you're like constantly falling
down more and it takes more effort to
like pick yourself up on like the
shadower side it's also like just a
whole new like set of movements your
body's just yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly would you do it again I [ __ ]
I became like a [ __ ] surfer dude when
when trying it for the first time like
yeah dude yeah I was like yeah did you
see me catch that wave
that's what it felt like that's what it
felt like
it's kind of like it's kind of like you
just gotta like learn by feeling and
it's so hard to describe what you're
doing so you're like you you see the
wave coming and then like you turn
around and then you like start paddling
and as the waves come you start catching
it like you feel the momentum going and
then you just feel like oh and this rush
comes up and then you like try standing
up I'm doing such a bad job of
explaining it
yeah and it's like you know a lot of
feeling yeah snowballing I guess yeah
there are technical terms but it's hard
right yeah and it's like what power
yeah and uh yeah I guess yeah what is
that what is that you want to drink
you want to drink some of the alcohol
all right should we shall we bring the
alcohol out no if you insist car all
right this video is sponsored by
expressvpn you know what's not fair the
fact that Netflix hides thousands of
their shows and movies from you based on
your location see you might not know
that what's on Netflix in your country
is completely different from what
someone in the UK or Japan has on this
but using expressvpn you can control
which country you want Netflix to think
they're in expressvpn is over 90
countries to choose from so every time I
run out of stuff to watch I just switch
to another country to unlock all of
these new shows and here's the best part
guys it's not just Netflix it works with
other streaming services too what if I'm
feeling a bit homesick I just pop up BBC
iPlayer guys because if you didn't know
I work for the BBC and sometimes like
you know I I need to visit my boss so
stop paying full price for streaming
services and only getting a fraction of
their content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com trash taste don't forget
to use our link so you can get three
extra months of expressvpn for free
that's EXP
essvpn.com trash taste expressvpn.com
trash taste Link in description back to
the episode or what we've got for us
here Chris okay I've tried so many of
these because of you good afternoon
apparently we found uh one in our fridge
so I said you give gifts
yeah
Cheers Cheers
Cheers Cheers Cheers getting fit
carb loading rights bro we got carb
loadings live it's nice yeah from
Fukushima Fukushima nice nice
man if you like surfing though um you
know who started surfing recently who
Felix oh okay
he I saw I met I met him for the first
time with with Connor the other day it's
really nice blue kitty yeah that's Felix
trap what's he done he's a YouTuber yeah
he was a nice bloke yeah it's
interesting like I think if you met him
without knowing anything to do with him
like yeah normal bloke yeah and that's
the essence of why he's successful
he's a very like nice down to earth guy
um he's saying you're not Chris please
one of the first things he said to me we
went to this Batting Center right round
one yeah yeah yeah yeah you know hitting
Bulls like he does he loves it I've got
a [ __ ] scratch the balls and what
like Felix and I'm just standing
watching he just told me a story of how
in Sweden one of his teachers told him
that someone got hit in the groin with a
with a baseball died and I was like this
is a very good conversation like the
first 10 minutes that I've known you
someone like having their balls battered
and dying from it and he's like yeah
don't don't do it that's possible that's
what I determined I've debated that for
like 10 minutes it is nuts just like
explode
shock heart attack yeah he didn't really
go beyond that right it was quite an
interesting sort of opener to our
friendship
um
how do you responsible yeah what'd you
say to that I just did that oh and it
was like well it's your goal now I was
like
very surreal we went to this like vegan
restaurant where they were like we have
a CBD menu would you like to see it and
we're like yeah all right they brought
out this menu and you can just like lace
your drinks with CBD oh yeah yeah which
is just literally water there's nothing
but we did it we tried a fair bit and it
just just rubbish yeah it depends on
like kind of a weird CBD yeah yeah
if CBD did something it wouldn't be a
thing in Japan they would bounce like
that because they they have a zero
tolerance policy on drugs or anything
like that yeah yeah unless it's alcohol
cigarettes in which case go [ __ ]
crazy yeah and they give you free yeah
rejuvenating the Japanese economy we are
yes yes doing what the Japan government
has asked us to do as young and it's
kind of crazy how short-sighted that
announcement was I just can't fathom it
but also makes total sense to Japan
shall we let in foreigners rejuvenate
the economy take advantage of the
weekend no let's make all the young
people alcoholics fantastic strategy
what could possibly go wrong I'm so done
with the whole [ __ ] why is Japan open
I think by the time this episode's out
they'll probably yeah probably there's
literally no more phases it can be they
keep inventing like another phase so now
at the time of filming they're on the
Thanos face
a tour company but they don't supervise
you yeah yeah you have to be on a on a
package tour
but for any but for individuals for an
individual but yeah and you're
unsupervised yeah what except you are
supervised they just the tour agencies
have to call you up to be like hey
seriously are you following the yeah
that you gave us and it's like and you
just have to be like yeah I'm in front
of the designated salmon restaurants yes
I'm having most fun yeah like this is
ridiculous it's so it's basically
nothing's changed like you're going from
an organized group tour with other
people to an organized group Tour by
yourself just just hurting their own
tourist economy really I don't know I
mean I've got a lot of comments from
people who are like I'm losing my Tempo
in Japan I'm going in Spike to South
Korea instead and it's like
[Music]
it's just very short-sighted and I just
don't know why they haven't turned
around yet and that was one thing going
about the UK game at the Europe
traveling to America everything's just
so he's moved on yeah yeah I remember
just I I flew directly to the UK to
Belgium and I landed the airport and
there was not a mask in sight yeah and I
was just like yes
yeah I know Master good and they've
played their part well but it's just
like I'm so [ __ ] done with them now
yeah I think it's frustrating for Japan
we talked about this on one of the
episodes just like Japan's kind of
lengths upon which they want you to wear
masks and the the yeah like they they
enforce it in such weird and bizarre but
even though there's no mandates
it's all Theater now yeah it is like you
know you go into a restaurant and you
have to put on the mask so like you'll
go in before you get in the restaurant
off the street and put the mask on
you'll sit down and then you can take
the mask off and it's just like what
about this makes any logical sense
because the walk from the entrance to
your seat you could you could spread it
but not when you're sitting there
coughing eating alone oh yeah when we
when we flew to wack and I remember
every time we even remotely spoke they
kept telling us to stop talking yeah
yeah because they were they were like
this you know because of coven and stuff
on the plane no we're wearing our masks
and stuff
we were just talking at like a normal
volume we weren't being loud and it was
just like
it's like oh my really we still we can't
still can't talk really is that I think
it's just your voice there yeah I'm
afraid on a bullet train with Connor
maybe eight or nine times and I'd say 50
to 60 those times I'm not talking stuff
shut the [ __ ] up
here's the voice of like Dragon he's
like well he might not close down the
carriage yeah the windows are starchy
yeah
I Can Feel the Bass just like enter
their body
it's like it's just like every time we
just we're speaking we were speaking
very we were way quieter than we
normally yeah and it was just like every
single time they just kept being like no
talking hello are we in a library like
what the [ __ ] is this it still feels
like you know the first day yeah to go
from life where it's things have just
moved on to Japan where it's not yeah
it's just very frustrating yeah I don't
get it it's just frustrating that like
even the stuff that was like proved to
not really have any effect on the spread
of kovid either
[Music]
you know you go with your family to a
restaurant yeah and then they put all
the dividers up and it's like I came
here with my family to this restaurant
and they put these dividers up and it's
like yeah between you all like you know
you know maybe you're in a relationship
with someone and you're even kissing
them all day and every day and whatever
and then you sit down this restaurant
there's a divider it's like why are you
still yeah and if you dare touch it they
like you know because sometimes you know
you're just like oh wow yeah and I feel
like they're very sensitive when it
comes to foreigners following the rules
as well oh yeah that also is I mean I
remember the one time that we went to
like the RAM and sikkimen restaurant
together and it was like oh yeah it was
like me Joey and Connor and uh basically
for some reason this guy just had it out
for me and I don't know I don't know
what it was because like for you only
for me right because every time I would
like take my mask off to like take a sip
he'd be like [ __ ] Sonic just running
up to me going uh yeah it wasn't like a
whole taken I was like literally just
yeah yeah yeah I just want to take a sip
of water next to like a guy without a
mask on a Japanese guy without a mask
just going ham on this like [ __ ]
[ __ ] tsukuman Ramen and then I swear
every time I like even like touched my
mask you know when you like make a sound
like the dog just like perks up I'm just
like
so after after like two three times I
would like just touch my mask like take
a sip of the water and he just
I I felt really annoyed for you yeah I I
wasn't I was about to tell him off
because I was sitting next to gone and I
was doing the exact same thing everyone
in there everyone in the restaurant was
not wearing a mask yeah I was just so
annoying oh my God and I'm like he's
just trying to take a sip of [ __ ] what
do you want me what do you want him to
do like waterboard himself like
my massage
it was yeah it was unfortunate yeah yeah
it's it's unfortunate because we have
now had a taste of what the wider world
is like you know the people like a lot
of
um like when they've asked people one of
the reasons why they don't want to come
to Japan is because they're like how
strict they still are about uh I think
that's that's the concern as well if you
say the doors open now and everyone can
come in uh you know a lot of foreigners
probably wouldn't wear the mask outside
no yeah and then that would be in the
media like foreigners come in Japan but
they're not wearing masks
the few foreigners that have already
somehow managed to come in in the past
couple of months I've seen like 95 of
them they're not [ __ ] wearing any
masks yeah and it's like well yeah no
[ __ ] because it's like it's been proven
now that it's like I mean at this point
now the hardest thing is ridiculous you
know you go outside the moment it's like
a furnace yeah yeah sorry it's like
that's what the government's been like
you can take the math yeah the
government has said that's okay guys
don't take the mask off nobody has yeah
instead I if I walk down the street I'd
say probably 95 of people I see are
still wearing masks yeah 38 degrees 50
80 humidity literally unbearable and you
just it's really [ __ ] hard to wear a
mask in those conditions yeah it's like
I get if it's like say for example you
know you're in the middle of Shinjuku or
whatever right and there's like just
[ __ ] you know wall-to-wall people
everywhere right but like I remember I
was in shizuoka like two days ago and I
was in the middle of a [ __ ] field and
there's just an old dude there wearing
his mask I'm like there is not a person
in a 500 meter radius of you who are you
gonna get covered from yeah so you can
take it off bro it needs you know in
Japan it needs that critical mass Point
yeah for society I find that you know
you just need that Tipping Point if just
but no one has the balls to be the first
one to take it off it's really
frustrating yeah so the foreigners are
like let's show you how we do it and
maybe like these goddamn
foreigners fault he hated them it's all
the truth
yeah I don't know the whole it's always
frustrating to talk about because you
don't want to seem like your anti-mask
or something as well I don't think any
of us are yeah when I did the post it
must be a month ago when I talked about
how the government said you can stop
wearing masks outside yeah everyone
still was I did a poster I got a lot of
pushback for people like just wear the
mask you [ __ ] it's like it's like I
wear it on trains on planes on buses on
everything yeah buildings outside when
I'm away from people in the summer in
the summer I do not see the logic behind
it and it just drives me up the [ __ ]
wall yeah so anyway and I don't know
just all this stuff yeah piss me off a
bit oh hopefully things get better by
the time this video comes out I'll just
worry that when they let in foreigners
on mass you know we're talking right now
the cap is 50 000 people and before that
we were looking at 1.5 million people a
month coming to Japan so 50 000 is
basically nothing yeah but when they
push it up to
hundreds of thousands yeah and cases
probably will inevitably go up slightly
um
it's just like I I'm tired of seeing
foreigners
for all these sort of things yeah I mean
No One's Gonna correct them like no one
they can they can use as much as they
want and then you know and a lot of time
they they platform and vote on it's also
not the first xenophobic they're using
foreigners as a scapegoaters like
they've been doing it more subtly but
since before covert yeah it's just like
now it's just like oh now we have a
legitimate excuse to be xenophobic it's
like no you don't yes that's not how
that works I don't know I've also
forgotten what Japan is like with
tourists in this country now because
most of the time I've been here it's
been during covid rules so I'm like
because I've never really lived here
when the country was really open I don't
really count the first like three months
that we were here because that was just
like an extended holiday you know what I
mean
that's what it felt like well I'd say
it's quite nice that there's no foreign
the point where it's like if I saw a
white Post in the distance I'm like is
that someone I know
so I was like wait how did you get in
here it's like I swear going to play
every white person in Japan just knew
each other it's like oh [ __ ] I went to
Akihabara not too long ago harsh I need
to pick up a bunch of stuff for a video
yeah and I got recognized like four or
five times
one of the most common places yeah and I
was like yeah yeah gone like full force
here What's it gonna be like exactly if
you want to get spotted the most I just
say asakusa yeah my experience it was a
weird experience as a foreigner going
into the American Embassy in Japan
everyone just thought I was American and
every time I went in like the visitor
the immigration then they're like no no
this way this way and I was like no no
I'm I'm not I'm not American I'm like
what are you doing yeah yeah
four separate occasions I had like
people think I was American and like try
to tell me to go to the the American
citizen thing because I was like the
only white Duty there and I was like oh
this is okay this is weird and I was
like I wonder if God got this
I definitely didn't get that they're
like oh he's where you belong that's all
right
trying to get a green card okay I see
you just married an American as well
okay okay yeah that was weird and I was
like oh racial profile
oh that was weird though that was really
bizarre okay for the American Embassy
yeah I've never been into an embassy
before that wasn't the Japan one in the
UK yeah in Japan oh really no why would
I why would I have gone why don't you
just like British Empire times it's like
a really pleasurable State it's probably
the best Embassy in Japan
it was like even walking apartment
blocks up to the thing that had [ __ ]
tons of security and I was like whoa
yeah you walk in and they're like oh
reservation for Bear Chopsticks
that's weird it's weird it was very
intimidating going into American oh
American Embassy is terrifying yeah
scary going into
that was terrifying
why not because they're like I went
through this whole thing and then
because you guys got yours on the spot
right no they just said they was
approved I didn't get that yeah that and
so that that was terrifying well you
didn't get approved on the spot no I got
refused
they were like you're already American
yeah
just come back with your actual passport
all right so you know so you go to this
like there's like three inspections
right and yeah this feels pointless yeah
when you hear the word interview I
thought we were going to sit down with
the dude yeah but then I may realize oh
I guess the amount of people that are
coming doesn't make sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah why you want to laugh
nothing mate
he's building up to something I know so
you go into this embassy it's terrifying
you're like all right everyone looks
depressed and miserable uh yes so we go
through it go through the first two
things I I changed my appointment date
so then that caused so many problems
already right and they were like the
date is wrong on the file like I changed
the appointment date and they were like
it's not what it says on our system like
can you please look again and they
looked again and it was yeah and then
they were like
typing vigorously for 10 minutes so I'm
like
all right everyone else is way quicker
than this yeah yeah I wait she goes
around back with my info like my
passport and stuff I'm like what the
[ __ ] is happening it comes back she's
like all right go on the next thing go
on the next thing finally go to the
interview yeah and the interview is not
what you imagine you don't sit down at a
desk like I thought was gonna happen
yeah the glass screen and someone it's
like you're going to a bank yeah yeah
literally a bank teller yeah like kind
of thing and they just ask you questions
and I don't know what they asked you
guys but they just asked me they were
like
um so what do you do for work and I was
like
I'm I'm a YouTuber same here same here
and then and then I don't know if you
had this as well then vigorous typing
for like five minutes yeah no I didn't
have that oh typing for like five
minutes and I was like
starting to get a little sweaty so I'm
like this is a long time literally like
I I want to say three to five minutes
total right me just standing there where
everyone else getting asked questions
like that and I was like did I answer
wrong like that's a YouTuber not on the
list but I'm looking up on a YouTubers
and then she calls someone else over
whisper something and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I do like why I don't think I've
done anything wrong and then she's like
okay
um if you won any awards or anything I'm
like
they don't really give them out for what
I do
YouTubers
clown right let me explain it
yeah I was like I just was like I don't
think anything that would really apply
yeah and then she again types again for
another 35 minutes she's really nice
though but it was just very like
unnerving yeah everyone else was getting
asked questions and then yeah yes yes or
no then she goes right so can't give you
a Visa today and I was like what
what I just answered two questions what
do you mean and then she goes but you
know uh it'll probably you know it'll it
might be approved and if it does it'll
just add two days to the process right
that'd be a piece of paper that in big
says refused and I'm like what and then
it says due to administrative
processings apparently the system was
down right it was terrifying because it
said refused yeah on the website it said
refused as well and it didn't say
anything about systems being down and
for like a week it's just said refused
and I was like it's just [ __ ]
yourself we have to cancel the tour like
yeah like what like what's what's going
on your place
how would you get an American visa uh
well I have to get one for December yeah
there's boxing chess thing so gotta do
all this so I'm just scaring the hell
out of me so I emailed like the the
lawyer on a Friday Japan so like first
day for American yeah being like help
help what is this what is happening can
you please explain what's happening
thinking Oh They'll reply they're like
never replied so the whole weekend I was
freaking out and I'm like what the [ __ ]
is happening is this bad how bad is it
is it fine it's probably fine right I
think I know it's fine but it's kind of
scary it says refused and pig and then
then like halfway through our cycling
thing it finally said um processing and
I was like all right good we've got 10
of the loading bar done yeah and then
like near the end of the cycling it
finally said approved
yeah for the entire time doing the
cycling thing people would be like can't
wait to see you in Nashville can't wait
to see you in Salt Lake City can't wait
to see you in New York and I'm thinking
if I get there what if the Visa gets
denied and I can't go what would have
happened if you couldn't go oh we would
have finally I would have had to cancel
the tour yeah
I would just hold an iPad
Connor's face tips
we've got a different visa for the tour
yeah yeah exactly see I had the complete
I had probably I've been to the American
Embassy a couple of times you know
because my Esther got denied one time
right yeah if Joey got it yeah no way
and so I had to apply for a business
Visa the first time around right and I
kind of had like a similar situation
when I got the business Visa yeah
um whereas like I didn't get it
immediately but then I eventually got it
but then this time around with this tour
Visa I was just like the one was just
like so what are you doing I'm like I'm
a YouTuber he's just like oh you're the
first YouTuber I've ever interviewed oh
yeah really yeah and I'm like well there
you go you just gotta laugh I will say
it is it was a terrifying atmosphere
because it's these three Americans
interviewing people yeah all you hear is
like what is your job yeah your job what
is it and then they say something uh I I
don't uh do and they're like what is
your job and it's terrifying yeah yeah
these people it's like an interrogation
yeah and these people can't really reply
and in uh in English yeah and it's just
like These Guys these people are trying
their hardest to speak in English which
is terrifying yeah yeah because these
dudes sound intimidating as hell because
they're just shouting and then oh this
one dude in front of me got rejected and
that was really sad and he was about to
like kick off and stuff obviously can't
really kick off in the embassy but that
meant like he's about to throw hands
yeah it really worked up damn yeah I
mean like my interview was like pretty
easy actually I think it's like similar
to Joey where they asked me what I what
I do it loud to some people will like
get racist yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
terrifying yeah yeah
unfortunately like even if even if some
of the Japanese people could speak
English you know I'm sure like getting
shouted out was not helping their the
stress level and the English language
skills but not like I got the same
question and they asked me what I did I
said YouTuber and then I I knew us I
knew I was in for like like a long
explanation where they were just like
what is that yeah yeah they were like
how did you make money
so you asked me how I make money and I
go like oh you know I go I have like
advertising sponsorships and everything
like that I have different areas revenue
and then he goes who's who like who puts
advertisements on it and I'm like oh my
God oh my God where ah this is going to
be this is like literally explaining to
your dad like how YouTube works and how
you make money and then I go to the I go
through like the [ __ ] five-step
process of explaining to your grandad
how you make money doing your job
and then and then after this five minute
long explanation here he goes did you do
anything before YouTube and I I go put I
put a cup
I'll have you know I used to work for
the BBC and then as soon as I said that
he's like all right Visa approved
wow it's like probably the best one the
woman literally just said what do you do
and then she said what are you doing and
I was like I'm doing a tour and she's
like what do you do where are you going
what are you doing and I'm just like I'm
doing a tour with some friends and she's
like sounds fun all right your visas
approved oh it was like 30 seconds yeah
I think I just gotten lucky on my day I
think you just got home yeah yeah
because I think normally what they do is
they pull up your application to look at
it yeah but I think they just had like
my piece of paper to go off of yeah what
I told them yeah they were just like
yeah I don't know what you're doing so
I'll hand it up to someone else in two
days maybe I had an easier time because
I applied for a business Visa before
yeah maybe maybe yeah I don't know why
is it that you know when applying for
Visa applying for like passports and
[ __ ] like that out of like all of the
documents that you need in your life
that you want the most information about
it's the hardest to get anything about
Visa or passport information yeah like
you send your Visa off for like if you
send your password off for like a visa
application they're like I could be done
in like three weeks a month I don't know
you're a [ __ ] package of Amazon you
get like a [ __ ] hour by hour like
breakdown of where this package is I got
my passport delivered to me and I was
[ __ ] myself yeah thinking that the
passport would get like lost in the mail
oh yeah right in the UK it'd be like
such a rates
yeah did you get recognized a lot in
England a few times yeah it wasn't too
badly luckily right yeah
so yeah yeah I mean like it's it's it
was weird like the biggest change I know
is this time was that since trash days
you just get recognized of like a [ __ ]
on more well like I didn't know if like
your audience was in England or like
mostly in Japan
mostly in America and then England
almost in America right should be me on
that tour for Japan so yeah
I guess so they're born Japan you've got
the trash taste Mega tour every American
city these guys come it's gonna be fun
the broader Japan was like me in a room
like five pounds a ticket five dollars a
ticket
it's just like my hypothetical tool I
just made it
like juggling
[Music]
we're gonna do Journey Across America
yeah
Across America I'd like to I I do I'd
love you know I'd love to travel across
America natskin I did have some plans to
do something year the covered was a
thing yeah unfortunately but uh he's
just too much of a diva now I think he's
driving me mad we want me to join across
Japan I could have killed him because
every like I was like I had heat stroke
really bad and my ear was exploded and
every day it was just a nightmare I'd be
like okay let's get rolling who's ready
and then about okay Joey natsuki and
that's kid's gone just disappeared yeah
and he's a toilet and he didn't he just
go off and smoke like a packet of
Marlboro cigarettes every like 10
minutes yeah and he drove me I had to
keep calling him back to be like all
right come on we're gonna film that's
keep having smoking breaks and then he
was like I need a toilet and at one
point I watched him walk to the toilet
and just as he restore he'd like do it
and just disappear and he just driving
up the wall well British construction
yeah yeah
but uh yeah I know I'd like a lot to go
around America I'll hear your review
from your tour yeah you can tell me
which one would you wish hypothetical
tour of Chris it's been me eating
Camembert
every city
it will be it what's your local cheese
in Oklahoma
sliced plants
just be in a room slowly but surely
gouging on well since you did like UK
content you think now that the like
World's opening back up you're gonna
like do more outside of Japan now that
there's an actual opportunity to do so
yeah absolutely like I I think it it's
not an exaggeration so I've kind of done
everything in Japan to some extent yeah
there's you know there's still a lot of
things I want to do here and I love this
country and I still want to travel it
but yeah I do want to start looking at
doing things outside of Japan more and
the reason another reason I'm building
up to this whole kind of wanted to get
the first ever been before the end of
the years next year I want to focus on
doing really big crazy physical
challenges had this I I basically up
until June this year I just resigned
myself to the fact that I'm 32 now I'll
probably just be unhealthy for the rest
of my life and then I'll die yeah and
then and having this wake-up call and
doing the cycling and the Spartan Race
and the boxing all this stuff it doesn't
have to be that way it doesn't have to
be a broad in a body bag any time you
see I can turn it around I can get fit I
can stop eating Camembert there is a way
out and so you know if this chess box
thing goes smoothly fingers [ __ ]
crossed as much wood hopefully by
December complete with my six pack which
I'll definitely have and winning the
chess boxing match and doing the Spartan
Race in the cycle I'll be in a
completely different sort of mindset and
fitness level that I can tackle bigger
challenges yeah like climbing you know
Kilimanjaro or Mount Everest wherever
I don't think I'll climb out of wrist
yeah people who are physically fit still
do that and die so yeah yeah think of
the v's girl look at the views
I died at the top of Mount Everest I
think average is too controversial now
you can't yeah I don't want to climb out
Everest I'd like to go to Everest Base
Camp I think it'd be kind of cool just
to see them yeah that'd be cool but I
just want to undertake lots of sort of
physical challenges and explore the
world a bit more yeah and open up in
that regard and that's what I want to
sort of focus on a lot more next year
yeah I still have Japan as my base I
think but I'll be like you know yeah do
some do crazy things yeah I just sailed
down the Amazon in a rubber dinghy the
Amazon River or I'm definitely gonna die
I'm gonna die on it you said you don't
want to be abroad in a body bag I think
you will be abroad all I want to do is a
trash day special up Krakatoa I want to
climb it to the top no questions asked
let's go practice but I'm no I'm serious
I do want to do lots of really cool
physical stuff that I never thought yeah
I'd be able to do it sounds weird to hit
32 33 next year and just sort of accept
that I'm just gonna be unhealthy and not
be able to get up the stairs to suddenly
have this flipping mindset and be like
I'm Gonna Get Fit I'm gonna do
everything I didn't think I could do
it's made things a lot more exciting and
give me a sense of direction that I felt
I haven't had the last sort of eight
nine months sounds like yeah I know
you're like early 30s Awakening you know
I think I did because
because I am age
I didn't want to say that what was your
health results
next year Chris is going to turn up to
the studio in a Porsche licking upon him
in my [ __ ] Health Report it was like
oh [ __ ] this is not good yeah it
probably is my midlife crisis I probably
am going to live to 64 if I'm lucky so I
do want to do all this stuff while I can
while I'm physically fit yeah you never
know what can happen you know you could
hit 40. something could go wrong and you
want me to climb a mountain or whatever
so yeah I want to do it now yeah and
also people keep saying that even though
Gartner and I are the same age Garlic's
10 years younger so I wanna I wanna
reverse
despite both I think that's just the
Asian the best
when when I hit like 50 I'm gonna look
like 80. you know that's just how Asian
jeans work when I hit 30 Emma like 80.
but uh yeah so that's my that's the
direction I'm sort of heading and I say
yeah that's recommendable I feel yeah no
it's given me a sense of direction I
guess yeah yeah yeah right because uh
you know but during the uh the the trash
day special when we went skiing together
right that was uh oh yeah you're quite
[ __ ] every 10 seconds
I don't know what happened that day we
went skiing in January right yeah yeah
no no no no no no no oh yeah yeah yeah
the skin was good I was on top form then
but just kidding yeah you claimed that I
was lazy you're just enjoying it a
leisurely Pace you refuse to do anything
we have to race to the bottom
we've been a [ __ ] scenery you know
Chris was good he's a good skier right
yeah Christian's being lazy because he
didn't want to do Reds even though he's
very very capable of doing Reds you just
didn't want to put the work in to do it
and we were like we don't want to do
greens all day Chris it was like Luke's
second day of skiing ever and he was
still going down Reds in yeah rolling
down it's still going down
if there was like the beginners and then
like not the biggest yeah and then
Christian not the beginners for a day
and we were
yeah because I I remember when we were
filming the special the trash day
special I was just like on my ass for
half the time and somehow I still made
it down there like First Hill for you
because I looked up and I'm like Chris
is on his ass right now sliding down
what's going on I don't know what
happened that day I don't know if
there's skis or shoes didn't fit but I
did really badly the trash so special
it's like the worst game ever yeah my
legs were broken right there was
something
ever as well yeah but I'll also tell you
what it was was when you went when you
were going to get you know your skis
your rentals yeah and the woman was like
how much do you weigh and Christmas
lights
we're all just like [ __ ] down
[Music]
but I think the equipment honestly
honest to God I think equipment was the
problem and yeah I didn't want my eyes
those people were lovely yeah
I I you know I failed really badly on
that and I wasn't happy so I mean the
snow is not snow it was slush yeah it
was it was not optimal because you're on
an ace for sure yeah it was like we were
skiing down Mr Slurpee yeah because
there was just like halts yeah and if
you fell it was extremely painful oh
yeah oh yeah you definitely hurt
yourself
that was a good trash day special so
that was really weird I remember I you
guys had been driving first or four or
five days at that point yeah right
Yamagata Zao and we met in the really
nice your car and you know it was
remember sitting with gun over by the
window talking about the you know
something serious something profound
like the geopolitical situation in
Eastern Europe at the moment and then
like no and then 30 minutes later I was
watching roll a [ __ ] snowman like oh
God
quicker quicker it's just the dichotomy
of trash taste
watching this like snowman ridiculous
sequence unfold and Jerry rolling
topless in the snow yeah she was like
bloody hell yeah what is this that is
the trash experience
unfortunately I was the judge wasn't it
yeah
because mine was like like three times
the size of theirs as well they just
can't rule the little thing and carved
it a little bit of a thing in it I just
might just look like an Abomination yeah
the most character shall we say
kind of the most like alpha male Snowman
[ __ ] I was like I genuinely felt I
was pushing a boulder trying to push
that we didn't have gloves yeah we
didn't have gloves yeah yeah yeah
exactly our hands are just numb yeah oh
my body was kind of numb as well yeah
what was the I mean snowman aside well
snowman aside what was the highlight of
the trash day special that one okay yeah
yeah
I really really enjoyed Hiroshima as
well uh most of that was like just off
camera though
um yeah
just like experiencing The Nightlife if
you're a Shameless yeah it was really
Sadie yeah and definitely Segways on
tottori yeah
we both did yeah yeah oh really yeah
yeah unfortunately
but yeah totally the the sand dunes were
like absolutely incredible but like the
city itself was just like right it was
like the most industrial city I've
probably ever been to the Yakitori was
amazing yeah
the thing about the sand dunes is one of
those things where in Japan there's a
lot of things that are oversold yeah
they're amazing I remember I went to the
Grand Japan Canyon in aomori ones and
it's just like a hill that looks [ __ ]
I'm like where's the canyon they're like
this is Canyon I'm like this is [ __ ]
really clutch clutching a [ __ ] strong
yeah yeah so I was like to totally
sanding it's gonna be like someone's
made a hill out of sand yeah and you get
there and it's incredible and if it's
crazy I've often thought of doing like a
short film there you could make it look
like the Middle East or something if you
frame it right yeah yeah yeah the same
way people were telling us that you
because we weren't allowed to ride the
Segways on the actual sand dunes
apparently they're really strict about
what licenses they give out to the any
anything to do with the sandwiches well
it's not allowed to drone either but I
did anyway
I think it would be cool if they let
more activities like
ran and run well yeah I don't really see
why it would be a big issue because like
it was just beautiful sand dunes and
there was nothing you could do on it
even though there was clearly a bunch of
you see it from distance yeah a bunch of
demand for stuff to do on it yeah yeah
you know there's paragliding but you
weren't allowed to go on the center to
take off right before the sand dunes
yeah yeah it was just really weird it
was kind of a shame really because you
felt like yeah you have this amazing
thing and they didn't want to let anyone
be able to like spend a day there yeah
like come drive here then leave after an
hour go to our wonderful City and see
the nothing sure the sugar sometimes you
think oh you wish they were a little
more lenient and kind of opened up to
the idea of maybe letting some cool
activities take place they're run by the
government or run well how was the horse
riding that was really cool that was
that they were really awesome as well
yeah the horse riding was so chill and
was so welcoming I feel like that makes
the experience ten times better yeah
yeah exactly and shut up and you're like
we've got film permission they're like
well we still don't really want you here
it's like ah
yeah they're like reluctantly you know
yeah yeah obliged yeah yeah I love
horses yeah yeah
well who's whose horse was the one that
was like couldn't stop trying to sniff
my horse's butts that was mine yeah he's
mine mine kept trying to overtake
Connors and Joey's on shrooms Joey's one
had just like done a [ __ ] horse he
bastard my voice
that moves yeah so he did yeah so it did
so we did this archery contest and I
remember this I was like we I was just
like recently go through the footage
um and for like mostly targets the horse
would walk in so slowly that when he he
got in front of the target he just
stopped yeah
it made me look like I was extremely
racist though
what because there was like this giant
white horse with this white man riding
on it and it was just like I could
imagine a different time when this
existed this image I was like of course
the white man is on the White Horse
Jesus what do you think of the uh
Stonehenge of Hokkaido better than the
real Stonehenge yeah honestly yeah that
area is actually really cool yeah the
Maui heads yeah the Maui heads the
[ __ ] the Buddha there was actually
like insane that's so cool that was like
definitely the cool spot yeah because we
can have good hotels in Hokkaido no
let's build a Giants of Stonehenge yeah
that Buddha is really cool though yeah
and yeah when you hit like the gong and
you just hear like the the sound Echo
and you hold down see this thing
yeah yeah yeah I also want a free drink
with my uh my fortune isn't that funny I
love it because they had like a fortune
yeah
it says like free drink at the cafe cafe
yes oh my God so you know when you walk
into the Buddha thing if you just turn
right as you're leaving there's a cafe
and it's this really minimalist Cafe and
then we walked in I remember the woman
was like what the [ __ ] it's like three
foreigners walked in and she's like what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing that's what
the Buddha would have wanted a free
trick yeah I think the most random
places we went to actually was this
German theme park oh I know it yeah and
I've been there which is which was
surprisingly a lot of fun it was a lot
of fun not because it had anything to do
with like Germany because you couldn't
couldn't even get pretzels there yeah
the pretzels yeah you could get pretzels
there so it's obviously like the first
hurdle yeah and the food that the German
theme park was like Ramen and sober and
it was like oh yes
I love my German dish sober yes
it was pretty good though yeah I don't
know yeah then we ended up just like
doing archery and just like okay
run off the road with my go-kart oh this
is Joey yeah you're right on my ass I
kept getting impatient with Jace I kept
ramming my go-kart into the back of
Jerry's go-kart but your card for some
reason was going like wait
when I won the horse the nailed it FPS
killed it I got the five-star hotel
Hiroshima because of that and they had
to sleep in the manga Cafe yeah they
actually like the manga cafes
that was like the 20th time I've ever
done this I'm just like this is just
another hotel for me Joey was like so
excited and we decided I'm just like bro
this place is gonna [ __ ] Saun us
because originally originally it was
meant to just be like one person who was
staying in the Market Cafe and then we
decided off the challenge that oh no two
people are staying in the Market Cafe
yeah
how happened it was something to do with
like they hadn't The Producers
convenient whatever
I thought it'd just be funny because
God's never stayed at among Cafe before
so I thought this was funny for the
video to go I think Joey was like yeah
okay okay so yeah it was surprisingly it
was like okay it wasn't like I wouldn't
choose to stay there no right right but
like one thing I did notice is that like
the everything was like leather and like
dark right I do not want to do like a
blue light filter on that [ __ ] place
because because the first thing I
noticed when I sat down I looked at the
PC and there's this link and one of the
most used links was the pornography Tab
and there was just like pages and pages
of pornography right and so we we do our
filming bit and we're going to go to bed
and then I hear someone in the Next Room
right and they they provide headphones
to everyone but it's like the cheapest
like the cheapest
yeah not noise canceling headphones so
you can hear like kind of like Statics
you like and the walls were like paper
thin as well right so you could hear
everything so all I heard was just like
static noise coming from headphone next
door and just like oh
and I'm just like
sounds like Connor's favorite holiday
[Laughter]
and uh you're a very faint
and uh I was just like this is this is
my life I [ __ ] hate Connor right now
this is
from five-star hotel it was more like a
three I was kind of we paid yeah we made
so much money for that we paid so much
money at the hotel and I felt like they
mugged us off a little bit we saved the
money on the manga Cafe yeah we did yeah
oh did you want to swap Connor he should
have said so because the whole point of
the challenge was that we had we wanted
to get the five-star hotel because it
sounds really cool right yeah yeah and
there's only like one in Hiroshima yeah
it's the one above the station and maybe
the Hilton or something and yeah
no it's a Sheraton yeah it was just
literally like a normal three-star I
don't really understand it costs so much
money yeah and it was like what the [ __ ]
one thing I didn't know I was good
having that as opposed to yeah one thing
I did notice about staying in the manga
hotel is that just staying in a room
with no windows completely [ __ ] your
body clock up oh yeah so much because
you you wake up and it's like is it 5
a.m or is it like 11 p.m I have no
[ __ ] flu right now
I remember when because God woke up
first because we were in the rooms next
to each other yeah and we were like all
right we have to go so God like knocks
on my door apparently the first thing he
sees is just me just [ __ ] stumbling
over just be like what time is it
because it's like when you're when you
wake up in a pitch black room you're
like I have no idea what time it is and
just like [ __ ] it's like it looked like
I so wish I [ __ ] filmed it because he
looked like a gremlin just emerging from
his cage it just it just looks to me
what time is it
oh my God
you're right mate
you've been in there for 30 years
but uh yeah that's been this episode of
trash Chase with I know this has been an
extra affable episode of trash taste I
nearly I thought about doing uh on the
trash day special there's a scene I
don't know if it made the Final Cut yeah
I'm like chasing after your car like let
me in man I was gonna do a trailer based
off that yeah do these Netflix
documentaries like the crime ones yeah
he was Mr affable until he wasn't
whatever yeah I was gonna do something
like that about how I was like a trailer
for a fake documentary like trash taste
exposed bitter taste and it's gonna be
about how I want to be the fourth member
but I'm not and do that I'm still
weighing it up before I should do it
yeah that should be good but hey look at
all these patrons though oh look at all
these lovely people they're just as
affable yeah wouldn't you say definitely
yeah be sure to stick around come back
for when I've got my six-pack
are you gonna come back when you have a
six-pack in a few months yeah so you're
gonna come back from this never-ending
American tour and be like whoa [ __ ] this
is a six pack we'll bring a six pack
I brought a six-pack from The Corned
Beef I will I will blow you away all
right we'll see we'll see you soon as
you see all right good luck I I wait I'm
I'm very happy to be wrong yeah yeah but
I know I'm not gonna it's gonna look
hilarious either you're gonna be wrong
but hey if you like to support the show
go up to our patreon patreon.com
trashcase also follow us on Twitter send
us your memes on the subreddit and if
you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and yeah go
thank you very much all right bye
[Music]